what's up guys
at the singapore zoo today for a very uh
special
occasion we're not here to take photos
of animals well kind of in a way we are
but
we're here to meet bruce now bruce is of
course is a singapore stray that was uh
picked up by the spca the singapore zoo
has taken him in they have been training
him for the past year and we're gonna
meet him we're excited to see
how bruce has come along what we're
gonna do with this project is we're
gonna create a nice video at the end of
this
and we're going to be working with our
technology partner logitech on this
project to sort of
piece it together
anyway i'm just excited to meet bruce so
let's go inside and meet him
he's a bit nervous
he's a bit nervous i think
hello
oh all right
[Music]
[Music]
big thanks to the singapore's doing the
spca for inviting us down here
now we're going to uh
edit this video we're going to put it
together for you guys to see the final
product
uh and big thanks to our technology
partner on this journey logitech
and with that guys let's get down to
editing this video
[Music]
[Music]
how's it looking mommy good zacky good
actually um we've got the color grading
and got the subtitles done but we need
photos i'll edit them on the ipad i'll
drop them in here send over the project
to you you put your magic to it
and i think the zoo's gonna be really
happy with what we got sweet let's do it
[Music]
okay so
in lightroom now take a look at some
shots you took of me zackie with bruce
uh
some very adorable shots i gotta save i
think these would be nice because these
will add a nice element of that
companionship there's something about
photography to me personally that it's a
moment because you know in our minds we
think in pictures
and it's at
that moment and i think we've caught a
couple of those though i think we could
put towards the end of the video that
we'll just make it pop even more
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right guys we just finished the
video and we are excited to show you
what we've created once again big thanks
to logitech who's our technology partner
on this the spca and the singapore zoo
zach did you have fun of course i did
all right without further ado
here's bruce
[Music]
this is gonna be fun
i love meeting dogs for the first time
that first moment they smell you
sometimes it's a little colder sometimes
you have to warm up to them they have to
warm up to you but you know that's part
of the bonding experience
he's gonna smell my dog though for sure
hopefully she has good pheromones for
bruce
hello
yes i know what you smell
[Music]
things won't be the same no more i'm
sure
[Music]
[Music]
to reach
[Music]
[Music]
because the fight or flight is
[Music]
i'm sure
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i must try to figure it out alone
[Music]
so as we just saw with bruce uh
he's a sweet boy he really is and it's
it's heartbreaking to hear about his
previous life before the zoo and
before the spca took him in i mean and
it's just
i mean there's a lot of dogs like bruce
out there and i just applaud what the
zoo is doing with what sbc is doing to
sort of
you know help rehabilitate him and he's
going to take some work i mean no doubt
about it but i mean any family out there
that's looking for a companion
um you just spend some time with bruce
you can see that he warms up to people
relatively fast and
so i hope someone out there who's got a
big heart
can do something great with bruce anyway
uh for more information click on the
link below and with that guys take care
and uh we'll chat in the next one right
right braha
okay time for a walk i'm gonna go for a
walk okay time for a walk here we go